connaissez-vous cette petite plante qui
aiment les milieux aquatiques
le flux tonnage en apprécient en effet
tous ces milieux qui sont liées à l'eau
comme les berges de rivières les étangs
où les mares malheureusement l'espèce a
vu son aire de répartition diminué suite
aux modifications et à la destruction de
ces zones humides
le parc naturel régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse à participer à des
actions de protection de cette espèce
comme ici dans cette propriété de
clairefontaine en yvelines
progressivement les étangs les mares
sont de moins en moins entre nous donc
sûrs et moins en moins souvent
voilà progressivement toutes les eaux
globalement qu'on rencontre dans les
milieux naturels ont tendance à être
beaucoup plus riche en matière organique
du coup l'espèce a tendance à régresser
à se maintenir que dans quelques petits
milieux un petit peu un peu stable on va
dire notamment marc forestière dans la
forêt domaniale de rambouillet ou sur la
propriété privée ici sur les temps c'est
la seule station de flûte aux agents du
parc qu'ils soient pas dans la forêt
domaniale donc pas géré par l'eau et 9
notamment dans le cadre de natura 2000
le fus tonnage ans sera inscrit à un
plan national d'action pour la
conservation par le ministère de
l'écologie charge ensuite au
conservatoire botanique national du
bassin parisien d'en rédiger la
déclinaison régionale donc ce plan a
vocation à améliorer l'état de
conservation de l'espèce à l'échelle
nationale aussi d'améliorer la
connaissance que l'on a sur cette espèce
sa répartition et éventuellement des
recherches sur l'écologie sur la
biologie de la reproduction est aussi le
plan national d'action a comme ambition
de fédérer un jeu d'acteur à l'échelle
nationale et de favoriser la
mobilisation des financements pour
mettre en place aux échelles régionale
des programmes de conservation comme par
exemple ici sur l'étang de la petite
verrerie à clairefontaine en yvelines
des travaux de restauration et de curage
des temps
ici la propriétaire a donc reçu une aide
financière pour la réalisation de
travaux
prenant en compte la biologie et l'enjeu
de conservation de l'espèce
j'ai été un peu étonné parce que a
priori je ne voyais pas de contrat mais
bien sûr je les ai permis d'entrée et
nous sommes allés à l'étang et c'est
comme ça que les aventures a commencé ça
ne m'a pas fait peur du tout pas du tout
au contraire se dit qu'on avait des
travaux à faire sur les temps donc on
était assez content tout les deux n'est
ce pas d'avoir bien ce projet quant à
partir du moment où on a su qu'on allait
avoir des subventions
donc nous ça nous intéressait beaucoup
les temps pareil superbe beaucoup plus
beau qu'avant
ah oui on est ravi à l'heure actuelle
l'espèce se maintient dans plusieurs
pays comme la belgique le danemark la
suède
mais c'est en france qu'elle est la plus
présente